el valor de siempre es 3 más que el
doble de x es una función de x bueno
vamos a expresar esto que nos dicen con
ecuaciones
es igual a 3 más que el doble de equis
siempre que alguien les pregunte si algo
es función de otra cosa lo que en
realidad les pregunta es si para cada
valor de x existe sólo un valor de g
si para cada valor de x de la entrada
existe un solo valor de sí para que esto
sea una función por cada valor de x en
esta función debemos tener como
resultado un solo valor de ella si
ponemos esto con nuestro diagrama de
cajita tenemos que x es nuestra entrada
entra a nuestra función que en este caso
es de de x y para cada x entrada debe
generar solo una salida si regresa 2
valores ya no es función se puede tener
dos valores de x que lleven al mismo
valor de g pero no un valor de x que de
2 valores
en este ejemplo es bastante obvio que
para cada valor de x tendremos un solo
valor de y si pongo un valor en x no hay
duda de cuál valor obtendré ni si x es
igual a cero que va a ser igual a 3 esto
va a ser cero esto se queda como atrás
si x es igual a 1 esto ha sido igual a 5
así que en definitiva ésta es una
función función
un sillón